have you ever seen the full moon appear
to change from this
to this to this
all in a couple hours
if so you've witnessed a lunar eclipse
the word eclipse comes from a greek word
meaning to leave for centuries people of
marvel that have a full moon appears to
leave during a lunar eclipse the incas
believed that lunar eclipses happened
when a giant jaguar ate the full moon it
turns out lunar eclipses happen when the
moon is covered by earth's shadow we can
only see the moon because it reflects
light from the sun the moon doesn't
generate any light of its own the sun
lights up half of the sphere of the moon
when earth is between the sun and the
moon we can see the entire lit part of
the moon we call this the full moon
but sometimes during a full moon earth
the moon and the sun all line up in such
a way that earth cast a shadow onto the
moon this creates a lunar eclipse
lunar eclipses can be seen from anywhere
on the night side of earth the two most
dramatic types of lunar eclipses are
total and partial during a total lunar
eclipse earth's shadow completely covers
the moon this means that no direct
sunlight is reaching the moon however
the moon is still visible during the
eclipse why is this as sunlight passes
through our atmosphere some of it gets
bent slightly allowing it to reach the
moon as in direct sunlight
most of the light that gets bent is red
or orange meaning that the moon appears
reddish orange during the eclipse
during a partial lunar eclipse earth's
shadow only partially covers the moon so
some direct sunlight is still reaching
the moon lunar eclipses only happen
during a full moon since it's the only
time in the moon's orbit where earth is
between the sun and the moon
and you might be wondering why isn't
there a lunar eclipse during every full
moon well the moon's orbit around earth
is tilted relative to earth's orbit
around the sun this means that the moon
often passes just above or just below
earth's shadow partial lunar eclipses
happen when the sun the moon and earth
almost but not quite exactly line up so
that the moon is only partially covered
by earth shadow total lunar eclipses
happen only when the sun the moon and
earth all line up precisely so if you
ever get to see a lunar eclipse you can
thank our planet for blocking the moon's
sunlight and letting us enjoy the
celestial spectacle